success on youtube is 20 strategy
and 80 psychology why because if you
don't have the right
mindset beliefs and emotions that lead
you
to taking massive action then you will
never
get results and in this episode of the
think marketing podcast we're going to
specifically be talking about
how to make money on youtube and five
money mindsets that are
critical to not just succeeding on
youtube but actually earning money
and hitting your financial targets
leveraging
the second most powerful search engine
in the world and the number one video
platform in the world
youtube all of that's coming up right
now on the think marketing
podcast
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean cannell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening
welcome this show is dedicated to
helping you learn how to get your
content noticed
and the latest money making strategies
working right now
online so whether you want to grow your
youtube channel
or you want to maximize video across all
of social media
this podcast is for you i'm so fired up
for today's episode
because it's actually a little bit
different than the past episodes that
we've done here on the think marketing
podcast
but i believe this is going to be one of
the most powerful episodes
that you've heard yet because it's
dealing with
really the inner game and the inner
foundation
of true success on youtube you know i
heard this quote
from tony robbins and it says this
eighty percent of success
is due to psychology mindset beliefs
and emotions only twenty percent is due
to strategy
the specific steps needed to accomplish
a result
and while you might debate that quote
i've seen this play out time and time
again why well we're living in the
information age
if information truly changed people we'd
all be
healthy wealthy wise rich you know fit
because there's tons of information in
the world but why is that not happening
it's clearly not just the mechanics
which are critical the 20
strategy of the right steps the right
strategies the right tactics
but it's obviously the inner game it's
do we have the right emotions do we have
the right mindset
do we have the inner framework to take
action and if you're like me
there's probably things you're
procrastinating on it's not because you
don't know what to do
it's because you haven't dealt with your
bs your belief system your inner game
your mindset
to actually take action on those
things if we simply implemented just a
percentage of the information we already
have
we'd probably be so much further than we
are now and in this episode
of the think marketing podcast we're
gonna be talking about five
money mindsets that i believe you need
to succeed on youtube
and that will help you serve more people
earn more
income and have a framework for really
not just
having short-term financial success on
youtube but really building
legacy building a business around your
youtube channel maybe you're a business
owner listening to the podcast
it's going to help you think about
youtube i think in a different way
and maybe you're trying to make youtube
your full-time living or
build it as a side hustle or you're a
business-minded content creator
in either case you're going to get a ton
of value out of this episode now
this episode is brought to you by the
video ranking academy that's our
signature online
course and coaching program for youtube
and you can learn more about it at
startvra.com
that stands for video ranking academy
startvra.com and
video ranking academy is uh the session
you're about to listen to is
from the academy so you're actually
getting kind of an insider
look at some of the sessions in the
academy it's a little bit different than
most of them
because the majority of video reagan
academy is about the strategy and the
tactics the mechanics of success on
youtube
our seven step proprietary
youtube framework that we use on every
single video we post
honestly on video influencers think
media think marketing
and it's what leads us to over four
million views a month right now
on think uh media our main channel
and so many students like thousands have
had success with this system
multiple students are getting silver
play buttons now it's really crazy and
so
a lot of the majority of what we talk
about in the academy is all those tips
and tactics and secrets
of like getting more views and
subscribers but this session
come on is dealing with psychology it's
actually dealing with that foundational
element of success mindset beliefs and
emotions
so i'm excited for you to hear this
session we'll talk a little bit more
about video raking academy later
but buckle your seat belt if you're
somewhere where you can take notes i
think you're going to love to take notes
on this one if you're driving
drive safe if you're working out come on
put in another rep for me right now if
you're walking your dog
give fido a little scratch on his head
and give him an extra treat later
and whatever you're doing i'm so pumped
you're here for the think
marketing podcast let's jump into this
session which is part one of two parts
on five money mindsets you need to
succeed
here we go all right welcome back to
video ranking
academy i'm so excited because in this
session we're going to be talking about
the mindset needed
to create a high impact and high profit
youtube channel and this is part one and
here's why this session is so
important you know i said the word
mindset and i don't want you to check
out here you know in the past i've
thought okay
if i just have the right tactics if i
just even have the right strategy
that's going to be enough to have
success on youtube but one of the things
i've learned
is that's just not true in fact the
three elements that i believe are
critical for success
on youtube are yes strategy what's that
i think that's the
tactics the how to's the tricks the tips
and i actually think that's about
20 of success only 20
now i think it's the tip of the spear i
think you see it at the top of the
triangle
it's the thing that cuts through the
noise it's the thing that gives you the
edge it's the video ranking academy
system
which is the how to the methodologies
the wisdom
it's the the tricks right it's the it's
not it's the strategy every battle is
won before it's even fought but
what i've learned is that there's
missing pieces in a lot of people's
lives that keep them stuck
so they don't actually get results with
the strategy the next one
is community show me your friends and
i'll show you your future
you may have heard that you're an
average of the five people you spend the
most time with
and i actually believe that this is 40
of the
equation you got to be connected to
people and this is this could be
your community of just who you're
learning from and listening to i know
for me
early on it was cds i was listening to
let me know in the comments if you
remember cds now it's all digital it's
all mp3s
i remember some tapes come on now
vinyl's back and trend but i was it was
the cds i was listening to the books i
was reading and it was the communities i
was pursuing
that's why i went to events to work on
entrepreneurship
and business development and my mindset
and leadership that's why i got around
others because i realized that who
you're around matters
and it wasn't that i wasn't hanging out
with my friends or spending time with
family it was that i was intentional in
my life to get around the right
community
because when you're around a community
that inspires you that propels you it
helps
stretch your thinking it helps you think
better it helps you believe for more and
look
you've got a community with video
ranking academy i want to encourage you
stay connected to the facebook group
stay posting in there don't think just
about what you can get from that group
but what you can give
to that group get in there when you're
around the think media team and you've
got
tony with his quick tips and you've got
heather and you've got melissa and alina
and you've got
people in the facebook group myself
we're in your corner when you've got me
and your ear with this course when
you've got
the video ranking academy students and
the interviews that we
have for you um whether that's you know
nicole or
steve or andrew or dr ihealth or ben
like and we have the vra show that
happens every single month
in the facebook group look this is a
community
that helps you stay motivated helps you
stay inspired
helps you keep focused on the vision i
think that's about forty percent
forty of success is having a foundation
of having people around you that are
going to help keep you focused keep you
inspired
you know the bible's clear about this
right this is like this is ancient
wisdom
iron sharpens iron but that means you
got to get around some iron you got to
get around some coaching
i remember one person it wasn't iron
sharpens wood iron destroys wood
it was iron sharpens iron that means it
hurts sparks fly
there's a little bit of grinding on
there that's what i'm here for
is to kind of coach you and to cut you
and to challenge you
and to say you were built for more you
were made for more and this is possible
but you gotta stick with it you're gonna
have to get uncomfortable you're gonna
have to be willing to change you might
have to change your mindset your beliefs
you're gonna have to learn something new
you're gonna have to step outside of
your comfort zone you're gonna have to
punch fear in the face
punch perfectionism in the face you're
gonna have to press
record every single week and do your
that's what you get in community and
that's why i need you staying connected
to the course
listening staying connected to the
facebook group but look
i don't believe that all that's enough
i think that the final piece is
psychology
that's the mindset and the confidence
piece i believe that's another 40
listen doubt kills more dreams
than failure ever will
that's true doubt kills more dreams than
failure ever will
look the strategy was there all along
the framework was there
the phone was in front of you or you're
watching this on the phone
the microphone for the phone was in the
other room or in your drawer
or in the garage or it's on amazon.com
for twenty dollars
and there's no excuse for it not to be
at your house on a tripod plugged in
and you recording videos except
the battlefield of your own mind your
mindset
your psychology and so that's why we
created the camera confidence course
and that's why we are obsessed that
this is the most comprehensive and best
youtube training
program on the planet because
it has all three elements this is why we
want you staying in the group staying
connected staying in the monthly q and
a's
well sean i think like i've heard the
tips before why are you doing them
well sean i think i've heard that
strategy before was it being implemented
on your channel
repetition is the father of learning and
the mother of mastery
so you need the repetition right
strategy psychology community
so this is why we're talking about
mindset and when it comes to money
your money mindset matters it's why your
confidence matters
because when you have confidence and the
right mindset and the right people
around you
and the right strategies you're
unstoppable
because you keep taking action because
it's not that you don't make mistakes
the people who succeed fail the most
increase your failure rate put out more
bad videos
the average successful entrepreneur
i read this stat has 2.6 failed
businesses
that means most successful business
owners
have had either two or three or four
failed businesses
so you think well why would they how
would that be possible they failed so
much
that's why they are winning now because
sometimes you win but sometimes you
learn
they learn more than anybody else the
only reason they got up again
and the only reason they didn't quit
because of psychology
probably because of the community that
was around them and then they retooled
the strategy
and took massive action so when we're
talking about revenue remember
influence comes first income comes
second
but you need money for the mission so i
want you to be bold
confident passionate and assertive to
say
i'm gonna make money i'm okay with
making money money is not the root of
all evil
the love of money is like that's greed
money is the root of good vacations
come on i mean you know like but for
real
like money is a tool
that can accomplish whatever purpose we
assign to it
the same money that
is used to exploit and harm
women in sex trafficking that same money
can be used to build homes and shelters
in school
for people to learn and to be safe and
to build families
we can think that the money is evil the
money is a tool
money is amoral and i know you have a
powerful mission
you are a purpose-driven entrepreneur so
you need money for the mission so i need
your
boldness and your confidence and your
assertiveness
to pursue income ethically by serving
others
to be foundational into everything that
you're doing you need money
for the mission and we got to think
different so in this session i'm going
to give you
five and then the next session i'll give
you five more money mindsets that have
helped me
in the journey money mindsets that have
helped me in my timing
of influence comes first income comes
second money mindsets that have helped
me
as a business owner and money mindsets
that are assuredly
related to building our influence on
youtube all right number one there's
only one way to make money
finding out what other people want or
need
and then providing those things to as
many of our fellow humans as possible
that's it there is only one way to earn
money
okay no matter your occupant your
occupation
so why does this matter this is video
ranking academy
what is video ranking academy about it's
about reverse engineering and starting
with the end in mind
what is the problem that you solve who
do you serve and what problem do you
solve for them
what do other people need
what do they want to watch what do they
want to learn what kind of content are
they looking for
this is do you think about the audience
first
there's only one way to make money you
find out what other people need
so in terms of your youtube channel
again
you might apply these strategies to your
current niche
you might pivot your niche to better
aligned with this truth of the universe
or you might even start an entirely new
youtube channel because
assuredly you should start with the end
in mind this is what reverse engineer
your revenue is all about
what do other people want like what do
they want to watch
this is how you start a youtube
automation channel what is popular
this is why we do keyword research what
is the search volume
now you might say well sean i mean but i
wanted to like talk about what i wanted
to talk about
well then you do you boo like do
whatever you want
this program's here to make you
successful and help you
discover the right video ideas that will
get views now the goal is to align that
with
your calling passions i'm not gonna have
a successful youtube channel teaching
people to sing even though people want
to learn how to sing because i can't
sing
so there's an alignment to it but these
are foundational money mindsets
dare i say that if you violate these
principles
that you'll probably lose it making
money as it pertains to youtube so the
key
is what do people want what do they need
and then you want to provide those
things
to look as many fellow people as
possible
think about this too this is amazing
this is serving people like when
when people want stuff they need stuff
and you give it to them
wow you made me laugh wow you helped me
learn something wow you made that less
complex
wow i was afraid now i've got confidence
wow i was worried about that first year
of pregnancy but man you were
a friend for me online you helped me
solve that you see how powerful this is
this is just money mindset number one
and i want you applying all of these now
listen
why youtube channels fail one of the
main reasons
businesses and youtube channels fail is
a
lack of market need
okay the example we use
although i'm actually confident you
could succeed at this
but if you were to create an underwater
basket weaving youtube channel
i did the keyword research and uber
suggest about 6 000 people a month
want to watch a channel about underwater
basket weaving here's the question
is there enough market need if
you want to make revenue from that now
if you've got
12 kids and you live in manhattan in a 2
000 square foot
it's probably not even big enough a 3
000 square foot
apartment in downtown manhattan
and you're gonna support yourself with
an underwater basket weaving youtube
channel there's probably not a big
enough
market probably not enough people
there's probably not enough
to ultimately be able to
sustain the vision that you have or the
income targets that you have
all i'm telling you to do is research
and work
backwards of how much market need is
there for what you have
i'm not even saying market competition
competition's good
if zillions of people are interested in
that thing well it's probably a good
market to be in was like a lot of
competitors well yeah there's also a lot
of people there
if nobody's there you don't want to open
up
a store in death valley where there's no
power
no water and no people except driving
through and trying to get out of the
heat you're like well there's no
competition you're like well yeah but
there's also no people
and so this is just one of the main
reasons businesses fail
there's a lack of market need there's
not enough market need
or or the niche your value proposition
position is not clear enough that the
market even understands
they need it okay number two the law of
income
you get paid in direct proportion to the
amount of value
you deliver to the marketplace
so your income will always be related
to the amount of value you deliver to
the marketplace
so answer this question as you're taking
notes and journaling
why is your video valuable what value is
it delivering to the end user
how can you deliver more value than the
competition
what is the unique value that you add
what even is the value you add
very simple and often overlooked
question why
should someone watch your youtube video
and how can you stack value in your
video
for example maybe there is competition
but you might say
you're going to be able to get the
answer faster in five minutes or less
i do what's taking everybody else 30
minutes in their videos
where do you think fast food came from
we needed food anyways it was like
what i could actually get it fast
now it's synonymous for unhealthy but
like the speed
is the value just drive up boom you got
the food
because there's better food to get but
it's not as fast
what's the value you provide and the
level of value so
by the way so these are my mindsets that
i was adopting that i was learning
and that i now have seen catapulted
us to the results that we're getting
today in our business
was our goal was to just
deliver an absurd amount of value now
if you're here and we're connected let
me know in the comments
did you receive an absurd or a high
level of value from me
maybe before you even did business with
me
think about that process and how that
happened
our income is good we support now
multiple people in our business it's
based on this law
of income we just thought man if we give
massive value and if i try to learn
everything i can
put out the best videos i can give out
the best free information i can
stay up researching and again if you
wing it
like if you put five minutes of research
into a video
well then that's about five minutes of
value isn't it
like if i'm reviewing a camera but if i
watch five videos read the blogs and
then also do this for 15 years
it's just a depth of value these are
commitments i've made
and understood that wow your income goes
up the more value you deliver
to listen to a specific marketplace
i am not helping women with pregnancy
like that's just not something that i've
been helping it's not a value i have to
give right so you have a unique
value but the amount of value you give
your income will go up
number three your financial success is
directly related
to the problem use to the size of the
problem you solve for other people
solve big problems you'll make big money
so listen two things the size of the
problem
oftentimes this law is applied
to the size of the problem in turn
in terms of if you're going to be a
checker or a bagger at a grocery store
the level of skill needed is paid a
certain amount per hour and that's what
that wage is
if you're going to be the manager of the
store you have to you're paid at a
higher level but you have a whole other
level of
of expectations you have to manage the
inventory you have to manage
the the skus you have to manage uh you
know
profit and loss of like did the produce
go bad and all
you got a lot else to manage and you're
paid more for it
that's the size of the problem but
listen
it's also the market size the amount of
people that have the problem as it
returns
as it pertains to youtube so again we go
back
to saying if you want to have big money
on youtube
you want to solve a problem a clear
problem
for potentially a large amount of people
so i had to do the math like when i was
thinking with amazon affiliates i was
like
okay can i help a lot of people
with cameras with lenses with these
types of things learn what i've learned
in video my background since 2003
again starting a video at a church it's
actually
somewhat of a complex complex problem i
thought about it like this whenever i go
to best buy
no hate on most people that work on best
buy but when i go to the computer area
or fry's
now this might be like an unfair
advantage like you know
i don't know street fighter like what
mortal kombat i'm trying to think of
like
sean cannell walks in but i walk in a
lot of times the computer department
and the sales person starts talking and
i'm like bro dude you don't even know
what you're talking about like you don't
know your stuff
like i know more than you maybe that's
not fair but like this is your job
like your job is to know what's gonna be
right for me how fast should that ram be
how fast is that monitor i remember one
guy was trying to sell me a computer
with an ssd drive that only had like a
hundred gigabytes on i was like bro
by the time i install like half of my
software this thing will be
well and you didn't even know what i was
talking about well so he was in over his
head and the job here's my thing you got
to know your stuff
you got to think about the size of the
prom you solve and
so i realized that when i went to best
buy to hear about cameras i was like
dude a lot of these people aren't even
educated
about their job in the camera department
so i just thought man i got to know my
stuff on think media
and people have the problem of what
camera do i use right
uh what do i need to know what's this
one versus that one
so that's a certain size of a problem
but then i also realized
well best buy employees they'll make
hourly wage
but they don't get commission last time
i checked
and i don't get paid an hourly wage like
nobody's motivated me or
paying me but i get paid by amazon but i
only get four percent
which is cool but it's not that much it
might go down because amazon does change
the rates
so then i was like man i need a there
needs to be a certain volume of people
like i need i'm helping people but my
way of like getting any kind of value
out of this transaction
is on a one-to-one basis it's not gonna
help me feed my
son that's coming or it's not gonna help
me feed sonya so i need this thing to
scale up
my wife sonia right and so it's just
knowing
that's tam total addressable market just
how big's the market this is the keyword
research how many people are in this
niche
how many people have this problem how
many people want this thing how many
people
are potentially after this right so
the size of the problem doctors or brain
surgeons
get paid a lot of money that's a very
complex problem and they've learned a
certain skill
so that's one way they're compensated
but also the size of the market
here let me summarize high ticket low
volume
high ticket meaning you only have a few
customers it's very expensive to work
with you
like imagine this you know if you did
some sort of a freelance coaching or
consulting business
and it cost ten thousand dollars to work
with you but you served the client for
an entire month
and you only did 12 clients a year you
just have 120 000 income in a year
kind of like a you only need 12 people
how many customers you need 12
i mean i so i put out i got i mean a
couple hundred views on my youtube
channel but i only need 12 customers
okay that's one way to look at it or i'm
going to
talk about pop sockets you know and i
need like
a million kids to like buy 13 year olds
you know like to hit the age limit of
uh like because you have to be 13 to be
on youtube technically and i'm sure kids
set up the
okay uh and so size of the problem like
volume so market size or size of the
problem these are just money mindsets
and money principles for reverse
engineering your revenue number four
money is the consequence of serving and
providing value to
other human beings it's not the goal
this is a mindset that served me
it's very powerful money is a
consequence
of serving and providing value for other
human beings it's not the goal
so my attitude and my spirit that i've
tried to protect and i think it's
important your heart your mind your
spirit
your motivation has been look i need
money for the mission
but if i believe this to be true and i
have no doubt about this to be a
universal truth
you know i'm a man of faith and i know
that god wove this into the fabric
of the universe that when we provide
value to other human beings when we
serve and
help others that it will be impossible
for us for that to not return
to us like uh
he that is generous will be refreshed
like that when you're generous with your
time your energy
your money you still got to be smart
because by the way we have other laws
they all build on each other
but you see what i'm saying so that
we're not saying
okay i'm doing this
with the goal of exploiting or trying to
get something or like it's
purely transactional we're saying no i
am just going to
serve and add value
to another human being
and then because i know the consequence
will be that money will come to me of
course
you have to eventually sell something or
else people can't give you money and we
have future laws
and money mindsets about that does that
make sense but this is huge for me
like it's just the consequence so
therefore i just am committed to
building my influence and let me be
clear about that
my belief in building your influence
because building your influence you
could think that's
un that's for you but my personal belief
this
mindset is that
john maxwell said leadership is
influence nothing more nothing less
like leadership is influence what is
leadership it's influence it's simply
leading somebody else
and the greatest leader to me is much
more than that but the greatest leader i
think that's ever lived is jesus christ
he taught us something called servant
leadership
it's a different style of leadership
it's a style of rather than
being served and ruling over others
it's his example was to wash his
disciples feet
so money is a consequence of serving and
providing values to others so what does
it mean to build your influence it was
just that the way i'm gonna build my
influence is by giving by being generous
by serving by providing value
and that if i do that and i'm gonna do
it over time
i will until then money will come to me
i'll be honest i might have even went so
much to an extreme where i was like a
little
too almost philanthropic which i don't
know if you could be but i actually
think you could be
it helped me to learn some of these
other things i know you need money for
the mission
but i hope this serves you because i
believe if you carry this spirit
into youtube you can build a legacy of
serving people of providing value
and then money's not the goal but it's
assuredly the result
of when you serve and you provide value
money mindset number five to serve
people you must first
get to know them you must understand
their wants and needs
okay powerful this is video ranking
academy
think from the customer's point of view
i want you to write that down
i want you thinking from the customer's
point of view i want you
thinking from the viewer's point of view
what do you think the viewer thinks
what's the viewer think about that hook
the way you open the video what's the
viewer think about the content
is that a waste of the viewers time
what's the viewer think about that
information what's the viewer think
about the audio what's the viewer think
about
about how organized the content is
what's the viewer think
do you think about the viewer first or
not a lot of people approach youtube
hey what up you know i'm excited to
start my channel and i want you to just
punch fear in the face and start
but like 100 videos in so today i just
kind of felt like talking about my
thoughts man
what's been on my mind you're like okay
what value is that adding to the
audience or today hey today my wife and
i were going on and i'm just nothing
against travel vloggers
but we talked to gary vaynerchuk about
this and he said this he said
most he said 99 of people are making
selfish content on youtube
benji went to gary vaynerchuk's office
in new york and
he said what's the biggest mistake
people make you said 99 of content
creators are making selfish content
he's like you wanted to go travel and
film it
and make a living off of it he said what
value does that provide to the audience
you can be a travel vlogger you could be
a travel educator
it's just do you think about the
audience first or don't you people
understand this stuff they feel it
you know if you're truly like working on
your craft come on kevin hart
joe rogan like i think about people
who've worked on their craft to crack
they spend a whole year to make one
comedy routine
to entertain and serve people so that
people laugh
dwayne the rock johnson highest paid
actor in hollywood also the hardest
working
like it's crazy the work ethic he wants
to serve people
entertain people so
if you want to serve and and win on
youtube you want to think from the
customer's point of view i just want you
thinking about the viewer first
like if you're thinking about the viewer
and
if you are understanding them and
thinking about the customer you're going
to win
and to serve them though you got to get
to know them so you got to understand
their wants and needs this is why we're
also
this is why you just don't make videos
that you want to make
or title the videos the way you think
you should title them you're doing the
due diligence to think
how would they say that how would they
search that in the search bar i'm doing
the keyword research
and i'm researching blogs and i'm paying
attention to trends and i'm doing my due
diligence
because i'm digging deep to find out
what people's needs and wants and
emotions and feelings
are because then i'm creating content to
serve others
dude how are you going to lose on
youtube if that's what you're doing see
how powerful this is
and here's why youtube channels fail is
they are not really in touch with
customers through deep dialogue
write this down if you have youtube
videos
play them for friends and family members
okay don't even do that because if you
have somebody who'll tell you the truth
like so if they're a friend who's like
kind of critical that's actually
probably a good friend like even a hater
like let them pick your video apart not
your mom because your mom would be like
honey it's so good the video is amazing
you're like okay well she's not really
your audience
you got to get honest feedback about
your content you got to be willing
to just get better this is not to
overwhelm you it's not for you to be
discouraged not for you to be like
dear god i got a long way to go it's
about getting one percent better with
every upload
but you got to get in touch with your
customers and here's why businesses fail
and youtube channels fail
they don't actually really understand
the viewer they don't really they're not
really in touch
one of the best ways to understand the
viewer is to talk to them like literally
get on the phone with them
you got like 25 people in your audience
find a way to like get on the phone with
them
hey how could the videos be better
what's like what what's going on about
like doing the work
this is why send out a tweet post on the
community tab what videos you want to
see from me
how could i make my videos better what
do you think the best businesses do hey
how can we make this product better
if if you want your smartphone company
to make the smartphone better and you
want to give them feedback
then why aren't you willing to hear
feedback about your youtube channel
if you want to have a stronger marriage
don't you need to get feedback and
change some things and be willing to say
you're sorry and be willing
you got to be willing to have deep
dialogue about real issues
so change can be made so that a
difference can actually happen
in someone else's lives so the reason
though a lot of businesses fail
they're out of touch again why does the
restaurant owner come out
and say how was the meal was pretty good
bread was great
drinks were great sam was kind of dry
they listen they think
shoot man we got to change our process
they don't go
like you have good taste don't you know
that dry salmon is the way
like if we don't have the attitude of
service
humility willingness to change
willingness to have deep dialogue with
our customers
with our viewers even if that's one
person and get one percent better
then we are probably not going to make
it on youtube
so here's my question to you which of
these money mindsets do you
need to work on in your life what was
your aha moment
from this session so far if you're
watching the video podcast
on youtube tell me in the comments below
and if you're listening to this on
podcast maybe just think about that or
even write it down what was an
unlock an aha moment for you out of
these these mindsets
over the years have been really the
framework and the foundation
of uh success on youtube and it is what
has helped me build a
financial freedom a five figure high
five six
high six seven figure multiple seven
figure business
step by step brick by brick this was the
psychology the framework
and guess what this is just part one so
next week on the think marketing podcast
we're gonna talk about
five more money mindsets and so make
sure that you're subscribed
wherever you're listening to this and if
you got value today
hit the like button or share this with
somebody or pass it along to maybe
somebody else
that is looking to create extra streams
of income that's looking to pivot their
plan
maybe a business owner that is looking
to leverage youtube somebody that you
think would love to think marketing
podcast shoot him a text
shoot him a tweet shoot him a whatsapp
shoot him a
messenger shoot him a snapchat message
shoot him a tick-tock i don't know if
you can do that but uh
definitely would mean the world to us if
you shared it um
listen today's episode was brought to
you by
uh video ranking academy and if you want
to learn more about
uh video ranking academy this session
came right out of the academy
you can go to startvra.com to see our
best offer for that program if you
want not just this psychology the inner
game the mindset but you also want
community it's video ranking academy
includes a private facebook group and
it's the most powerful community online
for people that are purpose-driven
entrepreneurs that are wanting to build
their influence and income
with youtube you don't just get the
private facebook group
you don't just get the world-class
online course that you can access from
anywhere
on the app on a computer on your ipad
and all the step-by-step training but
you also right now at the time of
recording this podcast
get two tickets to our event grow with
video live
included in our special offer that we
have there there's a few other bonuses
there's the facebook group so if that
sounds interesting to you
you can of course check out the show
notes um or the youtube description but
go to startvra.com
and our offer at this time is over 80
off on the entire bundle
of training tickets to our event um and
all the other bonuses that you get there
and uh that changes from time to time
but we are running an incredible special
right now
and so if you're ready to crush it with
youtube and not just to get the right
psychology get your mind right be
connected to a powerful
community come on be surrounded with
purpose-driven entrepreneurs in the
private facebook group and the monthly
group q a coaching which you get for
life by the way like
once you get lifetime access to this
program we do coaching calls every month
we have the vra show with tony every
month where we have different interviews
with
tactics and tips from students um man
we've got
uh the tip of the week with tony tony's
tip of the week it's it's crazy of
everything that's happening so anyways
go to startvra.com to see all the
details and get
80 off of enrollment right now
um for our signature youtube course and
coaching
program that brings us to the comment
i should say review of the day
having over 15 years in marketing i
still learn valuable nuggets from sean
and his team
every day his unwavering faith comes
through as a voice of truth and is so
refreshing
to have a grounded team that shares
their values together in
all areas of life clarity is key and
being clear
is shawn's biggest strength this podcast
will change
your life subscribe to it and you won't
be sorry and more importantly
punch fear in the face and get going my
man
felt house appreciate you glad you've
been punching fear in the face and
appreciate the kind words listen
if you've been loving the think
marketing podcast whether you're new
here welcome
whether you've been here since episode
one thanks so much for being here
if you haven't left a review and rated
the podcast on apple itunes it's
actually one of the most powerful ways
you could say thank you uh for the value
that we are sharing
every single week for free by the way if
you haven't if you've just been
listening on audio
and you haven't checked out the youtube
channel there's bonus videos live
streams q and a's and things that we do
on the think marketing youtube channel
so if you just type in
think marketing in the youtube search
bar or youtube.com forward slash think
marketing
um you can get not just the video
podcast version
but a lot of extra videos as well uh but
thanks so much for that review and if
you would do a review that would be
amazing and uh if you could think of
somebody to share this with and you know
share like comment pass it along
um we're on a mission to help 10 000
people
10 000 purpose-driven entrepreneurs
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with youtube and online video
and then sustaining that success
without losing their soul creating the
life
and habits and
principles to sustain that success why
because sometimes people grow big
businesses
they get some success we see it on
social media right you see a social
media influencer they break down
you see someone's marriage break down
and listen you're not ever going to get
judgment from us
we understand that we all go through
hard seasons in life and our friends who
go through hard seasons we stand with
them
but what we've learned is that sometimes
success can be one of the hardest things
to steward
and so not only do we want to help you
become wildly successful
so you can support your family give
generously give to the causes that
matter to you
but we also want to help you achieve
success without losing your soul
which simply means that we don't
climb the mountain reach the top of the
mountain only to realize
we climbed the wrong mountain or we got
to the top
but everyone that mattered most in our
life was left behind
you know i stole my definition for what
is true success
from john maxwell and it's simply this
that at the end of my life i want the
people closest to me
to love and respect me the most i'll
admit i've got to work for different
organizations
i've been behind the scenes and seen a
lot of leaders in different industries
in entrepreneurship and ministry and
church
and i've seen a lot of good things and a
lot of bad things and
i've seen a lot of public success but
sometimes i've seen private lives
that were not going so well
and again i really was just making an
observation
observation i got my own problems i'm
not trying to cast judgment
but i am paying attention and i don't
want to reach the end of my life
at the time of recording this my wife
sonia is 26
weeks pregnant with shawn bradley shawn
my first name
bradley her dad's first name kennel ii
come on legacy i don't want to reach the
end of my life
and have tons of success on youtube
millions in the bank
and my kids never saw me and i never
connected with them i don't want to
reach
the end of my life and i sacrifice my
health on the journey
i don't want to reach the end of my life
and my friends go you know he was kind
of a jerk
behind the scenes man he was i was just
kind of hard to be around
i mean he projected one image online but
man behind the scenes he was just super
grumpy he wasn't super happy
it's it's kind of that's that's the idea
of you have external success
at the loss of your soul so that's our
vision and our dream here
at think media is to help you be wildly
successful
and we believe you could have both and
we believe that if you get into a hard
season
and you know recently there was a couple
who
teach on marriage and have a marriage
podcast and have a huge platform and
some of the most successful people in
personal development
announced they're going through a
divorce and look no judgment but we need
to
have observation and it's like
man even up into the last couple weeks
before it it was like man everything's
cool and we're making out and
everything's good it might have been i
don't know
sometimes things can can uh can turn
quickly but typically that's not how it
goes
typically cracks in the foundation
started long before
they manifest in maybe some extreme
thing
it's a pretty heavy stuff at the end of
the think marketing podcast but what's
the point of all this
it's simply saying that we're on a
mission to help 10 000 people create a
full-time living doing what they love
with online video and then sustain that
success
by having building a life and having the
purpose and practices and principles
for sustaining that success and true
success in all areas
we want to be world-class entrepreneurs
not just in finances but in health
come on in legacy in generosity
in family in all these different areas
and by the way we have not got this
thing figured out
heather taurus sean cannell sonya kennel
isaiah taurus melissa caputo tony
ariola omar el tacori yo we're on the
journey with you
but that's our value system is that if
we got to go a little bit slower
but we can bring our families with us
we're not going to leave our families
behind
come on we do not want to
gain the world but sacrifice the things
that matter most
so that's what we're all about here at
think media i want to thank you so much
for being a part of this podcast
uh and uh thank you for being a part of
this community
and i don't know how we even got in all
of that
and i think i'm violating some kind of
podcast rule to still be talking at this
point and not ending quick and being
brief and bright and fun and be done
but uh this is what happens when heather
is on vacation with family
taking some time off and when i'm
running the podcast when she should be
come on heather where are you at
i'm i'm talking 40 minutes too long
because i have maybe a reputation of
being a little long-winded at times
but uh for real i mean we uh we believe
in running really hard working really
hard
but we believe in family man we believe
in taking time off and we believe in a
healthy
pace pace is a big thing for
entrepreneurs pace is a big thing
uh for uh slow and steady wins
you know i don't want to have bean pulse
success i don't want to spring up
quick and have a couple years of rapid
success we've seen too much of that on
social media
it's actually like a there's a
devastating landscape of people that
like
oh you know overnight success or like 15
minutes of fame and then boom they crash
and burn
i want i'd rather glow grow slow and
steady
uh you know think media is not about get
rich quick
it's about build wealth for sure
over the long haul that's biblical
that's proverbial that's proverbs
i don't think proverbial is the same as
proverbs okay hey
the think marketing podcast thanks so
much for being here
um rate review share and
uh as we close you know you know how we
end
action takers we talked about a lot
today that might have been a few other
things that we
got into but i think that was some
mindset stuff as well that's the inner
game right the foundation game the
beliefs
the values the core that drives us and
um
my question to you is what do you need
to do next what do you need to take
action on what do you need to put into
practice
which of these money mindsets was an aha
moment for you
today drop a comment write it in your
journal
calendar block it hey siri
hey alexa you know um
remind me to shoot that video record
that podcast
call that person hire that person
outsource that thing write that email i
don't know what you need to do but i
know you need to take action
because taking massive action is where
you get massive
results i appreciate you so much thanks
for being a part of the think marketing
podcast don't miss next week
for part two of these five money
mindsets needed to succeed
and until then keep crushing it keep
smashing it and we will
talk soon peace
you